in Afghanistan most households have one
television set so it's general
entertainment
they're mostly gentlemen faman channels
and slight to the slightly female skewed
but programs appeal basically to
families so in a place like Afghanistan
people gather around the television set
a bit like the 1950s in the u.s. it's
the thing to do to have dinner watch
television discuss the programs and then
go to sleep and people really have
nothing much else to do besides watch
television people can't go to
restaurants they can't go to the theater
even going to relatives homes in some
parts of the country is just the other
question so television becomes a sort of
focal point in a household and also I
think people just can't afford to do
things besides watch television I mean I
think even in the US for example you
know the sort of the poorer the less
affluent suburbs penetration of cable is
much higher than say the Upper East Side
in New York because people have other
things to do in the Upper East Side of
New York
so for us the important thing is to keep
it fairly general now of course the
market will become fragmented as you
know people have access to more
television sets to internet and so forth
and we know we're already recognizing
that so if we've launched a 24-hour news
channel for example in Afghanistan as we
see things we will probably have a
sports channel we probably have a
children's channel in the and the years
ahead in Iran it's a little bit
different television penetration is very
high at something like 80% of the
population a satellite has access to
satellite a lot of households have more
than one television set and so although
most of the programs we do you know
declare that they're to the family types
of soap operas and programs but it's
more female skewed than our channel in
Afghanistan that's what the advertisers
like and you know we believe that the
bulk of the viewers in a place like your
honor are women and so it really depends
on the market Afghanistan is very it's a
very unique case so the frozen in time
we had the opportunity to go in there
and obviously we're seeing you know
things resemble
as I said the us in the 1950s but the
change the rate of change is sort of
very much accelerated I mean Afghanistan
will resemble the Western world visibly
media probably the next five to ten
years so what was achieved in the West
over 50 60 year period will see happen
in Afghanistan over a very short period
of time probably 10 years old